[Music]
come on they'll have a look at you
where's that we need to be back in there
oh come on M I know you're trying to
help me but we should be dealing with a
bigger problem here he who remains I
understand and we'll get to that in
order to do that I need a lowkey who
remains we need to address the fact that
you keep disappearing well I I keep
disappearing we don't have
time you just disappeared I know and I
can't keep looking at it cuz it's
horrible what I thought he said didn't
know that bad I was
it it's terrible it looks like you're
being born or dying or both at the same
time it's really it's freaking me out
it's really painful it's not that bad I
can handle it how does it
[Music]
look
Obie
hello we have a little bit of a
situation we wanted to run by you obious
wow great to see you
again
that that's what's been happening wow
time slipping wait time you know that
yeah you've seen that yeah can you fix
that no it's impossible to time slip in
the TVA I know but we just saw it
happen
[Music]
yeah I've been pulled through
time between the past and the present
hello if what I saw is
true there's nothing to sound between
this world and arod
destruction only one way to find
out little good oldfashioned leg work
listen we have different styles you're a
man of action which is
fine I take a more slow deliberate
cerebral
approach it's really
[Music]
goodbye it's up to
us to save this place is this cracked
you
good whatever we
do we're playing
God we are
Gods but how do you
choose who
lives and who
dies make the hard
Choice it's him
you better run wall is on its
way come on you're the god of
Mischief always have been always will
[Applause]
be little over the top don't you think I
thought it was spot
[Music]
on